no tell you what how about just no shirt
at all let's try that
hey you guys hear that kind of like a
[ __ ] mom this is your chance to end it
are you ready
when have we ever gotten into trouble
ps3 ain't done yes and those are our
nominees for game spots game of the year
on the playstation triple for 2014 some
great games there and I want to start
off with a game that's kind of some
people are gonna find interesting that
it's there because it's kind of not a
full game but it's a it's one that I
know the folks who've played a defend it
very powerful the last of us left behind
Chris yeah man this whole full game
business alright look
this game is DLC it's an expansion to
the Last of Us and I think a lot of
people yeah rightfully wonder like where
where's is this a game I mean like what
does sort of the definition but I think
it's been pretty clear for a number of
years now that the evolution of what is
a video game and what is worthy of
honoring as a game it's just there's no
barriers it's broken down entirely it's
they vary in length and price and
experience type and Left Behind is an
experience that stands alone unto itself
it stands on the shoulders of the Last
of Us from its core mechanics and from
some of its characters but what it does
with these two girls Ellie and Riley and
what it does the gameplay mechanics like
this photo booth moment are incredible I
mean this is a moment like I see
whenever I see this moment you get a
chance at the end of that to post it on
your facebook ball yeah oh I see that my
heart as well because I know that that
person has been playing the Left Behind
excellent it was our game of the year in
February and just an incredible even the
batteries are right yes gave of the
month in February just an incredible
experience that really is still many of
the things that was great about the Last
of Us but then is it's entirely own
thing so so finta a little bit of a
change of pace 10 we're going from that
to the winner of the best voice work at
the Game Awards
Trey Parker which he was very happy to
be that Kevin Spacey I thought that was
pretty good
you know only in video games will Trey
Parker because of anything and we got
probably well probably the best
southpark game ever made yeah I mean
there have been a couple but I think
what's so great about this one is this
one was the love letter to the series
like they had everything in it they had
the CityWalk guy and they had just
everything every time you could possibly
you can possibly imagine then you also
got to be one like you got to be part of
South Park
and like stuff like this like what's
being shown right now is like cute
little additions to what is actually a
very solid role-playing game I mean you
have like the classes and yeah look at
this this is just glorious yeah you can
poop but like like look like say the the
combat system was sort of simple but in
that simplicity they were able to pack
in all of like the South Park humor I
think it worked really well
I loved the Jew class I play this video
class yes awesome it was a really
creative really sort of like
no-holds-barred spin on the classic
role-playing game and just it's funny
the dialogue was funny and what I think
I love so much about it is that this
season of South Park is so clearly
godlike they're all written about video
games really while they were making this
they were just spending a lot of time on
GameSpot on Kotaku and I'm not checking
all this stuff out and onto our next
nominee at Dark Souls - Gavin you've
been a massive fan of this series right
from the off what is it about Dark Souls
2 - makes it one of the best games on
PlayStation 3 you know I think the sense
of adventure is the biggest thing you go
off into these great areas you have no
idea what to expect there's so much
there's so much surface area to cover
but even beyond that every every area
has such a has such a different feel and
yet at all it all seems like it's still
one one part of one big universe and so
that consistency and yet that diversity
within that consistency is it's really
great of course you've got great boss
battles uh you know just looking at the
one that's on the screen right now
that's fantastic that's one of the best
battles in the game and so you just have
you know one fun boss battle after
another followed by you know great cool
areas to explore and as always that sort
of great Dark Souls esque storytelling
where it's not really about it's not
really about dialogue and it's not
really about characters it's more about
making your own story and more about
finding how you fit within this world
and trying to trying to see the little
pieces that fit into the bigger picture
and hear you talk about it Kevin it's
always a sense of discovery yeah really
thrills me as you're probably that and
the way that like you know a lot of
games we see out here you know we
they're awesome but we kind of knew what
to expect going in and even if that's
the case with Dark Souls 2 you know what
to expect going in but then
for them to still be able to capture
your imagination to make that
exploration that discoveries so
wonderful is incredible from one sort of
massive sprawling adventure to quite a
small one but one you can play over and
over again Metal Gear Solid Ground
zeroes and I'm gonna take the lead on
this one because this is one of my
favorite games of the year absolutely
and it kind of took me by surprise
because at the start I just thought oh
this is just like the prologue version
of Metal Gear Solid 5 whenever that
bothers I'll just mess around on this
one outpost I'll get a bit I'll be great
I'm like I had my ps4 and being
completely honest there were not that
many games that came in the first half
of the year that really grabbed me and
Grande zeroes was absolutely perfect
exactly what I needed I pumped hours
upon hour on to this game like playing
it over and over again my first run was
horrific I completed the story and I was
like oh that's it and then it presents
you with another mode but it turns out
that when you're just doing like the
regular standard first mission in it as
well but there are so many different
interesting ways to do it and it
reminded me of playing old games like
Rainbow six and project IGI where you
were basically infiltrating a base and
it wasn't so much like winning it was
the interesting thing it was figuring
out all the permutations messing with
the AI trying new tactics and ground
zeroes for me was a game that really
sort of encouraged type of play yeah
that's so good which is uh yeah so I'm
looking forward to seeing and how well
that does and our last nominee Dragon
Age Inquisition and one of the more
recent video games to make it onto our
nominees list and what is it about
Inquisition like say them do you think
makes them one of the best ps3 games of
the year
well it's a it's a Bioware game I hate
to be like Bioware game but like they
just consistently nail that ability to
drag the player into caring about your
character through all that customization
and then caring about the people around
you and the relationships there in the
party banter in this game I think is one
of the best things about it I know you
like loved the pretty better yeah I do
love the party banner and what's great
is that you know everybody's experience
is gonna be different when we go out
there out of the battlefield because
I'll have different people than you do
and there's so much specific banter
between very specific party members like
there are conversations that only two
particular people will have because they
are the people that they are and that's
that that's
really awesome like there there are
party members that we all love but the
thing is my party was so different from
a lot of other people's and yet I would
have had it any other way because there
were people that I I had grown to really
love and care about people talk about
characters right barely but knew these
people awesome those are our five
nominees I want to briefly mention and
does the game that's gonna probably come
up a couple of times over the next
couple of nominees and that hasn't made
a shadow of mordor in a word Alexa why
didn't make the PlayStation 3 nominees
list because it's known as the system is
so scaled-down it's pretty much
non-existent platforms yeah so those are
our five nominations that you can that
we will be choosing from and of course
you can as well in the Players Choice
Awards we will be announcing our winner
on gay frotcom on December 15 so make
sure you check back